[Music]
chris is with us in chicago hi chris how
are you
i'm doing well i'm doing well thanks for
taking my call sure what's up
uh first of all i just want to say thank
you because of the baby steps we've
gotten out of debt and our home to my
wife and kids you've become uncle dave
thank you well i'm honored thank you
i'm the crazy uncle
yeah uncle dave that's what we call you
um but uh my question is uh we are newly
into babysit four um and we should be
inducting fifteen percent but my wife
will be stepping away from work to go to
school full time so only i'm will be
only on my main income plus my side
hustles and we are wondering if we
should for goal 15 and just do minimum
403 b match provided at my job or should
we still push our investments to 15
why would you do that
uh why would i forego or why would i why
would
um my wife is saying because uh we're on
the one income
we it'd be kind of tight on the budget
um
that's kind of the reason i i'm leaning
towards the 15 and just keep living
in a blur means like we have been i'm
not like crazy like we were but how are
you paying for her college
uh i work for a university so she goes
full uh free oh wow
that's wonderful what's she studying
she's going back to be a teacher okay
and how long will it take her
uh we're thinking roughly about two
years good good okay and how much do you
make chris
uh with side hustles about a hundred
okay how many kids you got
four what did she make before
uh she made around 55. okay so you took
a
one-third of your income is gone you
took a 35
33 cut in your income roughly
and um and you're going to have a tight
two years in order to achieve a bigger
goal
which is her goal of being a teacher
and there's a sacrifice to get to that
goal
so i think you can make 15 and i don't
hear a reason to not do it i agree with
her that it is going to be tighter but
that's one of the sacrifices you're
making for her to go to school
is giving up her income and then she'll
get her income back when she graduates
and maybe then some maybe some on top of
that
depending on what she's teaching where
that kind of thing but um
i i don't see a reason to stop it yeah
just to keep going i mean i mean it's
what we teach chris now for two years if
you guys pulled back and just did the
minimum i mean you sound young i didn't
ask your age but
is it gonna make or break you
no but you miss out on that growth when
you guys still can be putting that 15 so
there's really not i mean
there's not a reason not to so i would i
think i think it's the tightness is part
of the decision you made when you made
the decision for her to quit and go to
school
and we made the decision for things to
be tight for two years
and that's not unreasonable you can do
that i mean um
and so uh
it's not like you're not gonna have food
on the table or something else so no i
think you need to stick with it that's
what i would do if i were in your shoes